When you are on the lesson page and reading,
this is a very important part of, certainly of my learning, on LingQ.
I listen a lot more than I read. I listen a lot because I can do it whenever I want,
in the car washing dishes and so forth, but then I want to get back to the lesson page for a mining,
so to speak, this text for more hints about the language. Noticing things,
seeing these yellow LingQs that I've created before.
Don't forget that you can adjust the font on your lesson page.
You can also decide whether you want to review...
in the settings you can either review
your words after every page, or not do that.
You can also set the settings so
that when you move to another page all
the words you didn't say won't
automatically be turned to white. So, be
familiar with all the settings, and make
sure you derive the maximum benefit from
working with your lesson page. That's a
big part of your learning.